biotonix et squeeze aujourd'hui se
trouve enfin avec mega sur the moocher
fraises tu sais pourquoi je dis enfin
mika oui parce que le 30 juillet je vais
demander de faire une vidéo sur ce jeu
il vient seulement de se réveiller ce
matin
le but du jeu est très simple c'est de
grimper sur cette chèvre qui a aidé d'or
qui dans un sommet très profond on peut
le dire est de dépasser la ligne blanche
mois la xbox
bakiev c'est à moi voyais à une araignée
à nos jeux venus du ciel tiens licka
attend à mumbai coincé mais non mais je
veux qu'il aille entre entre quoi c'est
lucas oui de quoi une minute par tours
pour dépasser la ligne blanche et celui
qui n'arrive pas dépassé la ligne
blanche une minute père voilà tu vas
perdre mais cas c'est que tu peux me
déplacer plusieurs membres en même temps
à part est dedans c'est mon gars elle a
eu l'impression que tu fais le truc le
plus épique de ta vie urbain alors
monsieur paquet fragile on a du mal tu
es bien mes petites lèvres ou pas je
suis tout mélange mis qu'un je t'attrape
lfl quelques poils qui met pas la ctu de
vianne on sait très bien la start up
italiens n'ont été très bien stars comme
ça tu es bien mais la lauvette faut
qu'un truc qui te fait c'était pas loin
de ses mécanos il a du mal
il a beaucoup de mal au c la perte mais
qu'ils arrêtent abandonne abandonne pas
mais qui joue et ça me sert un grand
silence c'était sûr on fait le mode
horizontal à plat à temps parce que
plein de mecs je suis en train de guérir
quand je sais parfois depuis 28 ans que
je regarde les boutons ma manette
monsieur michael ausiello mais juste le
doigt voilà le douaisis le doigt c'est
pas le droit sam sumyk allô bonjour
narac et fragile de nick cannon
l'américano c'est une grosse défaite
après tout pas rappelé non et toi tu
perds tu as pris ton chat maranon salut
jeune chat
lidge l'opposition allait bien poser ici
tient du coup de patte comme ça merci à
arette aromates au genou
roche ton paquet c'est lé ghana
calme-toi calme-toi mégalo c'est un jeu
indé qui coûte 2 euros calme-toi chi
calme-toi mikado non je te rappeler je
veux pas qu'il n'ya pas tu veux c'est
une auréole me suis cassé tabou vous
irez en enfer
je vais essayer de gagner un peu de
terrain pour faire une petite colline
sainte foy et à qui le connaissent
accord à égal avec c'est pas un problème
pour moi à plat sur la testicules droite
qu'est ce qui se passe
va-t-il réussir à franchir nos corps
musclé et voilà et techniques âge où ils
parlent plus absence de dialogue non là
je sais pas je monterai sur mon plan là
cette auréole s'il te plaît pour nous
deux ne passe pas gt non j'étais un
millimètre
un ministre mais n'en manque déjà pas
n'ayez pas garde
regarde a expliqué ensuite avec l'agent
même gpu peu fier mikaloff wet mais je
vois pas ta tête au la déception à deux
fautes et à madame il veut bloquer
regarder l'eau vous à fait être cédées à
des coups de [ __ ] comme ça c'est pour la
tête bien faite et bien la merde non il
dépasse pas la vie
c'est un cercle
je me sens pas très bien parce qu'il
s'est passé non non ça va ya un mois la
mauricie bague à l'aide et aux plats
mécano fois passée face aux fesses d'une
chèvre à moitié à bâtir qu'est ce qui
fait qu'à vous hop là ça veut pas chaud
à bitche arrête de la pompe par là que
[ __ ] mais c'est fou ça à temps mais là
tu vas da il a su côté des taux courts
en fait je pars tu peux pas passer à
celle aller vite vers la droite
on attend la visite à droite en fait
attention on va revoir le bic a bloqué
de la faim à temps mais j'attendais ça
plus qu'un nouveau film de marvel quoi
laisser saint affrique
mais non un petit mp sur ce dernier
instant on a vu mika qu'il tentait avec
sa jambe ou son bras chez plus de
manière inespérée vient la ligne blanche
non bah oui l'ami la pluie pour invoquer
t'as vu je me suis envolée d'hier à quoi
tu te port de lach quoi ah ah ah non
mais que par contre c'est vraiment
rigoler des complexes et tous neufs en
même temps je comprenne la caméra ce
moment met fin ce jeu si on plaçait pas
encore de lâches
c'était pour mieux la retoucher le smic
1 puis je t'ai fait surface bien plane
qua non
alors baggy plus gros corps de l'achever
4 h30 27 secondes 21 secondes d'ici six
à l'été lutte avec la coiffe ainsi que
sur des peluches toi allez olla mauvaise
foi salut ça va
jack hayes et s'élancer sur la piste
avec beaucoup de difficulté à l' matin
non attends ça tu aimes ça quand je
perds du temps médias locaux ça passe
comme on a appris à la piscine héros
c'est le drame
va-t-il réussir ta 26 secondes allez
mika meka musique applique allez mika
allez vas-y à lui calé 13 28 secondes
picard band secondes d'écart
tiens c'est un mot latin voix l'agencé
dia fois cette vidéo si ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à aller mais ça fera
vraiment plaisir un moteur fait un jeu
bien marrant qui coûte 3 euros 90 je
crois sur steam
bon j'avoue la durée de vie du jeu est
d'environ une heure kwh attire joue plus
j'espère que ça fera plus insouciante et
les deux nouvelles vidéos hot shots
monde pitt si je pars super vite remis
cas on s'en fout
ce